Brian they've all warned a Turkish
president aired one he needs to respect
the rule of law is Jiri asserts his
control over Turkey but will they
actually go beyond the rhetoric that's
not clear an era if you think about it
the EU has a partnership that's only
four months old now with turkey whereby
the Turks are helping on migration
helping to stem the flow of refugees
from the Middle East through turkey into
Greece and it's working the number of
refugees landing on Greek shores has
fallen some 10 fold just over the last
few months so the Turks are doing their
part when it comes to that deal the onus
is actually on the EU to hold up their
side of the bargain and to deepen their
partnership with Turkey by giving the
Turks visa-free travel to Europe by ria
kick-starting those membership talks
with Turkey that have been going on
forever so if turkey was - or if the EU
was to not do either of those or to push
back that could leave the real problems
for the you when it comes to the United
States secretary Kerry was here for him
it's all about NATO and he said NATO -
has standards have a listen NATO also
has a requirement with respect to
democracy and NATO will indeed measure
very carefully what is happening the
level of vigilance and scrutiny is
obviously going to be significant in the
days ahead
so you see there you know that warning
from the United States having said that
you know the United States needs turkey
in terms of its operations in Syria we
saw that over the weekend when as a
result of the coup the u.s. couldn't fly
its drones out of that Turkish air base
but it also needs Turkey in terms of
credibility it is the largest country
within NATO with a majority Muslim
population so there's a warning but the
the the barrier for or what it would
take for a real separation a real
divorce a real argument is pretty high
because the reality is the West really
needs Turkey right now Ryan this meeting
was also Boris Johnson's first as
Britain's foreign secretary how did that
go
no inflammatory comments on Turkey I
hope no no inflammatory comments in fact
Boris was on his best behavior he has
insulted he has denigrated the good name
of the EU he has offended many of the
foreign ministers here but if they felt
offended they certainly weren't showing
it we heard from federica mogherini
she's the EU foreign policy chief say
that she had a very productive dinner
with Boris Johnson last night in fact
all 27 of the other foreign ministers
were supposed to be there officially
they said they weren't gonna have the
meeting because of the events in Nice
some private toilet privately told us
they just didn't want to sit down with
Boris Johnson but you know look it was
very much a working kind of pragmatic
conversation with Boris Johnson we're
expecting him to come out any moment now
so we'll definitely ask him how he think
it went but the real I think also
interesting thing will be to see how the
relationship of the United States
develops into that and the US Secretary
of State is on his way to London and
he'll be sitting down with Boris Johnson
so we'll see where the special
relationship with the between the US and
the UK
goes from here Ryan is anyone asking why
Boris Johnson is actually there does he
have a role there I know that the you
know Britain hasn't actually left Europe
yes but you know that's his intention
and he made the comment that Britain
will always be part of Europe what does
he mean it won't be if it's not part of
the single market or a part of anything
else about Europe
welllook britain is formerly part of the
european union until it acts it's and
since it hasn't formally told EU that
it's going to acts 8 yet it has at least
a couple years to do that what they want
to really know from Boris Johnson is
where he fits into the brexit
negotiations there are sort of three
brexit ears leading those talks and I'm
sure they're asking him what his role is
going to be as the UK ex ago she eighths
their accent it's not entirely clear to
anybody for that matter what that is